well I'm on oh yeah right now a panel at
co-chair panel with dr. Joe Nye friend
and colleague organizing something we
call smart power we all know what a hard
power is we've seen it in Afghanistan
we've seen it in in Iraq but we have a
lot of soft power it's everything from
the power of ideas to the power of our
society to the power that can be
generated by our technology which can be
used for the general public good we are
the richest nation of the world we can
use that money for the alleviation of
infectious diseases and suffering and
things that nature so we have a lot we
have the bully pulpit when the United
States speaks as we are still the only
superpower everyone has to listen so the
manner in which we speak is very
important